- (Crowd clapping) All
hour we've had people
sharing their awesome tales
of hanging out with Prince.
So let's close out with something
that comes from Prince's
home state of Minnesota.
This is what I'm liking.
(upbeat music)
(crowd cheering)
Sixteen year old Shaine has
a huge passion for animals,
especially those with special needs.
So she decided to learn how to
make handcrafted wheelchairs
for pets, so cute.
She's made them for
small dogs, come on now.
Big ones, oh my gosh.
Even one for a tiny hedgehog.
It's so awesome! (laughing)
And she only charges people
for the cost of the materials.
We have Shaine on the line right now.
What's up Shaine? (crowd cheering)
- Hi Kelly
- Hello, first of all I
like the bright decorations
on your walls, that makes me happy.
- Thank you!
- So how did this all get started?
- So I've always had a really
special place in my heart
for animals.
And during the pandemic, unfortunately,
all of my volunteer
activities got canceled.
And when I found about,
found out about,
why so many disabled animals
get euthanized at shelters,
I decided I needed to
do something about this.
So, I watched a lot of YouTube videos,
and I eventually made my first wheelchair
and actually made it for a Great Dane
in Oregon named Cyprus,
and ever since then,
I've just been making wheelchairs.
And they can take from a few
weeks to a few months to make.
- Oh, you have such a great heart Shaine.
This is the sweetest thing ever.
You've taken your efforts
international as well, right?
- Yeah.
I recently made two wheelchairs
for two different dogs.
They both came from Saudi Arabia paralyzed
and when I made them their wheelchairs,
I was actually able to meet them in person
to give them their wheelchairs.
And I saw them use them,
use their wheelchairs for the first time
and it made me so happy.
So I was absolutely thrilled.
Their names are Scooter and Happy,
and they're now living at
a sanctuary in Wisconsin.
- (audience clapping) Oh my gosh.
You are such a beautiful
woman inside and out.
Like what a,
what a beautiful thing you're
doing for these animals.
That's so, their quality
of life is enhanced.
It's a beautiful thing you're doing.
Thank you so much, Shaine.
I'm liking your post right now, right?
- Okay.
(audience clapping) And
that's not all girl,
our season long pilot
pen makers of friction,
the go-to erasable pen of
the Kelly Clarkson show.
Want to celebrate those
creating fearlessly,
just like you ma'am.
So they're going to give you a
thousand dollars to help out.
How's that sound?
(crowd cheering)
- Thank you, oh my god, thank you.
- All right well keep it up